[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight when elon musk first
announced that he was buying twitter it
was pretty obvious the democratic party
would soon become unhinged not just
angry or annoyed in the way you're very
used to but instead legitimately
terrified and hysterical imagine how
you'd feel if an armed intruder broke
into your home at three in the morning
you couldn't exactly know where things
were going but you'd be dead certain
that everything was at stake
that's how democrats feel right now
because in fact everything is at stake
joe biden cannot continue to control
this country if you have free access to
information it's that simple
biden certainly is not improving your
life he's not even trying to improve
your life so the best he can do is lie
to you and demand that you believe it
but to do that he needs to make certain
that nobody else can talk because if you
were to hear the truth you might not
obey
how is biden going to pull that off it's
not easy
well one option would be to get men with
guns to tell you to shut up
most americans probably haven't thought
of that because this isn't africa or
eastern europe this is america and we
don't do things like that here and never
have
more precisely we haven't until now
but now joe biden is president and
everything is different
so today to herald the coming of the new
soviet america the administration
announced its own ministry of truth this
will be called the disinformation
governance board laugh if you want but
just to show you they're not kidding
around here
this board is not part of the state
department or any other agency focused
on foreign threats from abroad no
the disinformation governance board is
part of the department of homeland
security
dhs is a law enforcement agency designed
to police the united states and that by
the way has a famously large stockpile
of ammunition
so it's not a joke at all here's dhs
secretary alejandro mayorkas
we have just established a miss and
disinformation governance board in the
department of homeland security to more
effectively
combat
this threat not only to election
security but to our homeland security
oh so one of america's top law
enforcement officers just announces to
the congress that actually we're going
to be policing what you say and everyone
in the room kind of nods oh yeah it's
totally normal but here's what he didn't
say so america's told us that
disinformation is a threat to homeland
security now he's the head of the
department of homeland security so
presumably he would know since assessing
threats to homeland security is his job
but what he didn't tell us
is how he's defining disinformation so
here you have this new and terrifying
thing that the bible administration is
so concerned about that has created a
new agency to fight it
but mayorka has never said or even
hinted as to what it might be
so the man in charge of the
disinformation governing board never
defined disinformation
it's almost unbelievable when you think
about it
would you declare a war on a country you
couldn't name
would you sentence someone to death for
a crime you couldn't describe of course
you wouldn't not if you were a sane and
decent person
because you can't have justice without
precise definitions that's why we have
very large books of law that define what
is allowed and what is not
but they're not defining
the core concept at the heart of what is
effectively a new law enforcement agency
maybe that's because malarkas doesn't
want justice and neither is the
president he serves they want power and
to get power they plan to control what
you think watch my orcas explain
we have so many different efforts
underway
to equip local communities
to identify individuals who very well
could be descending into violence uh by
reason of ideologies of hate false
narratives or other
disinformation and misinformation
propagated on social media and other
platforms
oh
did you know that so one of our biggest
law enforcement agencies has men with
guns around the country doing so many
things
to stop disinformation and false
narratives those aren't even lies
they're just deviations from the
approved script america's told us again
that men with guns plan to quote
identify individuals who could be
descending into violence could be
descending
not people who have committed violence
or even been accused of any crime at all
dhs is instead using law enforcement
powers to identify and punish people who
think the wrong things that would be
opponents of the bide administration is
this dystopian fiction no it's happening
right in front of us
that means that joe biden's partisan
political enemies are now officially
enemies of the state
how is this happening in america
good question but it is happening
and biden's new thought cop in chief has
been revealed she's a 33 year old highly
self-confident young woman called nina
jenkowitz jankowitz comes from a place
called the wilson center that's a
non-profit named for america's other
mentally incapacitated warmonger bigot
president
ironically because everything is irony
the wilson center is itself a major
producer of yes disinformation but of
the neocon variety and for that reason
is heavily funded by the bid
administration
djangous is also because everything is
connected a former advisor to the
neo-liberal government of ukraine the
government were shipping tens of
billions of tax dollars to as our own
economy swirls down the drain
so you really can't make any of this up
it's too grotesque would you believe a
novel with this plot no you wouldn't but
it's happening and that's the bad news
the good news is everyone involved in
joe biden's new ministry of information
is a buffoon
they may be evil but they're also
ridiculous nina jankowicz is the most
ridiculous of all so you read about her
appointment in the washington post this
morning and you immediately thought of
the nkvd because why wouldn't you
yet even the nkvd even at the height of
stalin's purges never did karaoke they
were too dignified for that
but nina jenkins happily does here she
is
information laundering is really quite
ferocious it's when a hopster takes some
lies and makes them sound precocious by
saying them in congress or a mainstream
outlet so disinformation's origins are
slightly less atrocious
it's how you hide a delighted light it's
how you hide a little light a little lie
it's how you hide little idols alive
when rudy giuliani shared that intel
from ukraine or when tick-tock and flu
and sustained covet can cause pain their
laundering disinfo and we really should
take note and not support their lives
with our wallet voice or vote
since the point of show we're going to
say we're kidding we're making all of
this up it's not really happening in the
country you were born in but it is
happening that's now a law enforcement
official
it's also the person you just saw an
individual who brags about getting a
master's degree from georgetown
university in case you're wondering if
the entire academic credentialing
machine that sustains america's ruling
class is in fact a joke spoiled alert
yes it is a joke
this is somebody with so few useful
skills that she describes herself in the
first words of her own bio as a quote
internationally recognized expert on
disinformation
as if that's a job of some sort imagine
if one of your kids grew up to be an
internationally recognized expert on
disinformation the shame you would feel
the pain of knowing that truly and
unequivocally you had failed as a parent
after all those years of advanced
education nina jankowicz became an
internationally recognized expert on
disinformation and not only that
she can't even rhyme very well
what nina jankowicz can do her one skill
the purpose for which she was hired is
level partisan attacks on the other side
with maximum ferocity that is her real
job
now you may have noticed if you listen
carefully to the deity saying that every
example of disinformation her karaoke
performance
came from people who oppose joe biden's
policies is that a coincidence
probably not
in fact we know it's not because anina
jankowicz is telling
all the disinformation
is on the other side of the political
divide listen
most of the disinformation that we've
seen this highly emotionally
manipulative content is coming from the
right if you look at the top 10 you know
most engaged with posts on facebook or
twitter on a given day
they are usually posts that are coming
from the right and that's because the
right does deal on this highly emotional
rhetoric
[Laughter]
you'd have to live in a
self-awareness-free vacuum you might
even have to go to georgetown
university.or a sentence like that the
right deals in this highly emotional
rhetoric
says nina jankowicz
now it's worth noting here because we
can't resist that this very same nina
jankowicz once wrote an entire book
about how women can't use the internet
because it's just too upsetting for them
they're too fragile to read words they
disagree with it makes them faint
here's a direct quote from nina
jankowicz's book quote to be a woman
online is an inherently dangerous act
[Laughter]
keep in mind if you're a lady and you
were to i don't know order uber eats
you're exposing yourself to danger
this is the same woman nina jenkins
telling you that it's the right that
uses emotional rhetoric
now to be fair nina jenkins probably
didn't expect a lot of people to read
that in her book because no one read her
book it has a total of two reviews on
amazon but we did read it we'll get in a
moment to what we found because it tells
you exactly what we can expect from our
new ministry of truth under nina
jenkowitz
but first it's necessary to know a
little more about this person now she's
not simply a hypocrite she obviously is
whether she knows it or not she would be
too dim to understand hypocrisy what she
really is of course is a heavy for the
democratic party and she's done that job
flawlessly nina jankowicz the
disinformation hunter
once called the hunter biden laptop
story which is entirely true a quote
trump campaign product
in october of 2020 she wrote voters
deserve the context not a fairy tale
about a laptop repair shop
now did she give us the context or any
countervailing facts did she deliver the
truth about that story no of course not
she just read a bunch of lies somebody
handed to her on a card because she's a
useful idiot and now she's a law
enforcement official nina jankowicz is
repeating a lie
that was of course widespread on the eve
of the presidential election
and when she repeated it made it
possible for joe biden to repeat it on
the debate stage during a presidential
debate in case you've forgotten here he
is
there are 50 former national
intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian plan
they have said that this is has all the
care four five former heads of the cia
both parties say what he's saying is a
bunch of garbage
nobody believes it except of his and his
good friend rudy gianni you mean the
laptop is now another russia russia
russia hoax and that's exactly what this
is
okay just to be clear
this is a nightmare unfolding in slow
motion but this is the point we're just
gonna have to draw the line
no joe biden you can't have a federally
funded ministry of truth and no nina
jankowicz can't run it
period it's not your country you're not
even compass menace and you don't get to
do this to a free people peer-reviewed
this can't happen
and what is this
well if you want to know what's going to
happen look at what just did happen so
nina jankowicz made it possible for a
presidential candidate to lie from the
debate stage about a story that may have
changed the outcome of election
our election our presidential election
speaking of disinformation she's never
apologized for that
that's because a role has nothing to do
with the truth or stopping
disinformation her job is to restrict
any speech that challenges joe biden or
the democratic party
now you'd think that would be illegal in
this country as a federal employee
because we do have a first amendment
but nina jankowicz doesn't believe in
the first amendment as she wrote
recently quote the free speech versus
censorship framing is a false dichotomy
first of all here's a pro tip anyone who
uses the term false dichotomy is a [ __ ]
okay
that is one of countless academic
phrases designed to prevent thought
rather than facilitate it false
dichotomy means they're never going to
have to explain why their position is
correct or yours is wrong that is
dismissed with oh it's a false dichotomy
again that's an npr phrase used by low
iq people who for some reason run our
country all of a sudden
false dichotomy
here's what's not false at all
government censorship is banned by the
first amendment the first amendment to
the bill of rights this whole country is
predicated on that
but according to joe biden's new
minister of truth the first amendment no
longer
applies in this country because russia
and systemic racism watch
it's clear that actors like russia are
using those internal fissures things
like our systemic racism here in the
united states things like economic
inequality to amplify uh these issues
and and really make us distrust the
system
so we reached out to dhs the law
enforcement agency now in charge of
policing speech about nina jankowicz and
her plans to censor you from saying what
you think is true and they assured us
that they weren't going to do that
they're going to focus on human
smuggling and russia propaganda on
ukraine first of all it's not their job
to decide what you learn about the
border or russia or ukraine it's your
job you're an adult you can read
whatever you want
but of course it's not about that anyway
if you read jankowicz's book which we
did you will realize very quickly she
was hired to police domestic social
media use period quote i have hope we
can change the norms by which our online
ecosystem is governed she wrote in a
typically illiterate sentence this is
what our colleges are producing morons
you can't even write english
later in the book she encourages women
to go to law enforcement if they see
something online they don't like on
twitter she called that quote an
important step in the denormalization of
women's treatment online it's hard even
to believe our system produces people
like this she's an illiterate fascist
in another book jankowitz made it clear
that she's not in favor of government
regulation of social media when it
allows conservatives to speak freely so
she devotes an entire chapter to
criticize in the country of poland for
establishing its own ministry of digital
affairs polish officials said their
ministry was a way to quote deal with
rampant online censorship of
conservatives on social networks but
she's against that she's against the
anti-censorship program she's for
censorship
she wrote that poland is making a big
mistake
in pulling back censorship and we're
quoting poland's nearsightedness is
leaving it extremely vulnerable she
wrote and the solution she wrote back is
for the us government to quote lead in
regulating and conducting oversight
of people who disagree with the
democratic party on twitter so the truth
was never the goal
and we're quoting again we are not even
sure that facts can prevail over
disinformation jankowitz wrote we must
first begin with addressing social media
just to be totally clear
the means of the distribution of
information are the key to their rule
it's all they have they have nothing but
that if you knew what was actually going
on you wouldn't put up with this for a
second
and they know that
and the body administration knew that
jenkins wrote all of this
that's why they hired her
what you're seeing is a full-scale
attack on free speech in a country that
has been free for nearly 250 years and
it's happening at the direction of the
us government through a law enforcement
agency we can reveal that biden's
pentagon
another group with guns awarded a
750 000 contract to a group called
newsguard now that contract is for
misinformation fingerprints
newsguard is an organization that claims
to fight misinformation but in practice
is a censorship organization targets
anyone who challenges the people in
power newsguard is currently preparing a
blacklist of sites that contradict the
national security state's talking points
on ukraine and russia so this week
newsguard wrote a threatening email to
the news site grayzone informing the
gray zone that they're spreading
disinformation
because they're not reading the script
so here's how the editor of the gray
zone max blumenthal responded he wrote
this do you seriously expect us to
grovel for approval from the same
tentacle of the national security state
and financial oligarchy that has rated
cnn as a highly credible news source and
whose board of advisors is a grotesque
gallery of corporate propagandists
spooks documented liars war criminals
who've never faced the scintilla of
accountability for their actions
kind of overheated language is it true
yeah every word of it
so when joe biden's censors come
that's the way you respond hey pal up
yours you want some disinformation here
you go
you are a free person in a free country
and no law enforcement agency can ever
tell you what to think or say period
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight